I'm Brian Bluyn and I am a cup master with PAC 3285 out of Rockford, Michigan.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old Scoutmaster.
Hey, everybody, this is Clark Green.
It's summertime and so our next few podcasts feature on-core presentations from our archives,
And this time around I want to play an interview that I conducted with Mike Malone,
who's the author of a really fantastic book called 4%.
It's a history of the Eagle Award
And, as you may imagine, Mike's an eagle scout, so he knows what he's talking about.
It has a long tenure in scouting and produced a incredibly well researched
and very compelling book about eagle scouts.
As always, this podcast is only possible because of the generosity of the folks
who become ScoutmasterCGcom backers.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find out how you can become a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
We'll be back with our regular schedule of podcasts in a few weeks.
Until then, let's get started, shall we?
Michael S Malone is one of the world's best-known technology writers.
He was twice nominated for the Pulitzer Prize for investigative reporting
And you've read his articles and editorials and publications like The Wall Street Journal,
The Economist, Fortune and The New York Times.
He's the author and co-author of nearly 20 award-winning books.
Mike is, all importantly, an Eagle Scout and currently an assistant scoutmaster
of Troop 466 in Sunnyvale, California.
Now, in this centennial year of 2012,- the centennial year of the Eagle Scout-
Mike turned his considerable talent as an investigative reporter and writer,
as well as his extensive experience as a scout and adult volunteer,
towards a book that no doubt will stand, at least in my humble opinion,
as the definitive history of the Eagle Scout Award.
It's called 4% and subtitled the Story of Uncommon Youth in a Century of American Life.
I think it's not only an authoritative history of the award,
but it's kind of a meditation on the meaning and the spirit and importance of it,
And I'm certainly honored to welcome to the podcast.
Thanks for joining us, Mike.
Well, thank you, Clair.
So in the first chapter of the book, you call the Eagle the PhD of boyhood.
Yeah, I heard that along the way somewhere a few years ago
and I thought it was a brilliant metaphor for what Eagle Scouting is,
that it's a combination of learned skills combined with a final culminating event,
which is the Eagle Service Project that has to contribute to the larger world.
And if you look at it that way. it really is like a doctorate
and there's nothing comparable to it in American boyhood
There never has been. and it's really the apogee of being a teenage boy in the United States
And it's been that way for 100 years now.
What I really enjoy about the book- because it's a great read,
because it's a fantastic story. just the story of how this award came to be
and who has received it and what they went on to do is just a fascinating story.
And I think in one wise the history of the award itself is a history of the Boy Scouts of America.
We were talking just a little bit before we started the interview here
that that history has its ups and downs and its bumps and its troubles.
That's one of the things I really appreciate about your work.
It doesn't dodge any of those issues.
It's very honest.
Did you struggle with any of that?
Yeah, when I set out to write this book, I'm a lifelong newspaper man
Journalist. I'm a fourth generation newspaper man.
In fact I'm sitting here editing some copy from my 21-year-old son
who is now a fifth generation family newspaper man.
So it's in the blood
And it was very hard for me to even contemplate the idea of whitewashing this story
or turning into a hagiography of the March of Great Men.
That's just not my style.
I think the story is much more interesting when you capture awards and all,
And it's not like Scouting has a lot of awards.
I mean, it's an inspiring story all the way through
And, yeah, there have been some missteps and trips down the wrong path a few times,
But all in all I think those other things, those darker things,
actually make the entire story much more spectacular, much more amazing.
It's an awe-inspiring story?
Yeah, it really is,
And those bright moments are offset by the not-so-bright ones.
Let me tell you the genesis of this book, because it's kind of unusual.
I had taken a group of scouts from my troop back to Northern Virginia.
Two of the boys were restoring a Civil War battlefield and cemetery,
which sounds hugely ambitious
And it was, even though these are the two smallest battlefields
and federal cemeteries in the United States- Balls Bluff.
But it was quite an experience doing this
And as part of it we were going to be in the flag ceremony
in our Civil War uniforms at the National Jamboree
And we also marched in the Centennial Parade of Boy Scouting
down Pennsylvania Avenue in Washington DC
And I think there was 20,000 scouts in that parade.
It was quite a parade.
It was the first one of this kind since the first jamboree before FDR.
I was in the contingent at the very end, which was Eagle Scouts,
And each of us was asked to carry or wear something
that represented our career.
So I had the notebook, you know. I had the satchel over my shoulder
with the press card. but I looked around me
and there were guys dressed as department stores, Santa Claus.
There was a guy from Bermuda who was a diplomat.
There was a military officer and he was wearing
the full Hurt Locker bomb demolition outfit-
which was pretty tough because it was 100 degrees that day-
Just a panoply of distinguished middle-aged and older men
showing the wares of these remarkable careers
that had followed becoming Eagle Scouts.
And we started down that parade.
I was afraid a few of us weren't going to make it in that heat.
There were 80-year-olds with us marching at the tail end
of this massive parade of Boy Scouts.
We turned the corner and started heading down
towards the Washington Monument
And as we did, the loudspeaker shouted out
ladies and gentlemen, America's Eagle Scouts.
And the roar that came up from the crowd.
There was probably 50 or 60,000 people
lining that mile of avenue there,
The roar that came up for these Eagles,
And looking at these old guys with bad hips
and blimping and all that, and we all stood
a whole lot straighter and marched in formation
And I suddenly was struck by the relationship
between Eagle Scouts and American culture
And that story had never really been explored
And I just had to write the book at that point
It was an insane idea because I was buried
in a new startup technology company
and writing other books and teaching college.
But I just had to write the book
because I realized nobody else was going to do it.
There were no real plans for the 100th anniversary
of Eagle Scouting, so I decided to do the celebration myself
And the result shows the passion that you had for it.
Yeah, it's kind of a book that wrote itself.
I tore through this one.
Some books are very painful to write.
Spending three years writing about Steve Jobs once
was not the happiest time of my life,
But writing this book my fingers worked by themselves.
If we asked everybody who the first Eagle Scout was,
they'd probably come up with Arthur Eldred.
But there's a lot more to that story
and there's a lot more nuance and depth to it.
First tell me about the time that Arthur was a scout
and what was going on at that point in the history of the BSA.
Yeah, let me preface that by saying
we all know it's Arthur Eldred. but 15,, 20 years ago
I think, if you asked people who the first Eagle Scout was,
nobody would know.
I don't think the BSA was quite certain
And that was a fact from basically the 20s until the 90s
that people didn't really know about Arthur Eldred
until I think it was Boy's Life
or Scouting Magazine went out to find who it was
And even then they got the wrong photo.
For a number of years there was this square-jawed kid
out of a poster who everyone thought was Arthur Eldred.
And finally they found real photos of the guy
and he looks just like every other Eagle Scout
you've ever known in your life,
Kind of skinny, smart-looking as eyes
and a bit amused having to pose for the photograph.
You can really empathize.
I mean, Arthur Eldred is us,
except he's kind of more than the rest of us
given his career.
He got his Eagle in 1912,
and you have to understand that Scouting
didn't begin as a monolithic organization.
It flows out of multiple organizations,
the Daniel Boone Society, various other groups.
It starts out as basically a fad among teenage boys.
They hear about Boy Scouts in England
and they start their own groups and they turn into troops
and they turn into these sort of ad hoc organizations.
There were about four or five different Boy Scouts organizations
in the first decade of the 20th century.
They were all over the place.
And if you ever want to read the whole history of it
or read the Scouting Party,
which is the story of these early days
and the clashes of egos of the different founders
and all of that.
So Arthur Eldred was a boy living on Long Island.
His father had died.
His mother was concerned, like mothers today,
that without a dad he would get in trouble.
He had an older brother who was quite a bit older
who sort of stepped in as his surrogate dad
and helped rape him.
And this older brother looked around
and saw these emerging scouting groups
and thought, well, why don't I build one of these groups
and with Arthur in it,
and that'll give structure to his life?
So he went out and actually set out
to join another Scouting organization,
one that's long gone now,
but it was much more of a militaristic organization.
They carried guns around, they marched
and they were sort of like preparing boys to join the army.
It's not a bad thing to do in 1910
given the clouds forming over Europe.
But he had trouble getting permission to start
the organization or something
and instead he said, okay, well,
there's this other outfit at the headquarter down in Manhattan,
Why don't we join up with them?
and that was the Boy Scouts of America.
So they started this troop out on Long Island
and the boys did the usual stuff.
They didn't have a lot of money.
They sort of pooled their dough to buy uniforms.
Some of them didn't have uniforms.
It was very, very casual.
It was sort of closer to Baden Powell's dream
of what scouting was
than what we think of today
of 60-member scout troops
meeting in a church gymnasium
with a trailer full of stuff, going camping
and all that.
And this was boys meeting in the evening
like in a barn or something.
And Arthur, at the time
there was very few documentation
on how to be a Boy Scout.
There weren't really any ranks at the time.
It was all in development.
And so when the first Boy Scout handbook appeared,
boys across America-
there was probably 100,000 boys across the United States
who were involved in the organization at that time.
they gobbled up that book
because it not only showed them all the scouting skills,
I mean, they had been dealing, working with Baden Powell's old book
and various other books about the outdoors.
Now they had an official book
and they went at it,
They consumed it and began earning the various ranks.
And the ranks were kind of what they are today,
up until first class.
So you had 10% class first class
And then it all kind of went crazy
because there were merit badges,
but there was only about 15 merit badges
and they were divided in two different categories.
There was sort of like an outdoor category
and then there was the home and citizenship category
And you either earned the star or the life.
They weren't sequential,
They were kind of in opposition.
And then there was this thing called the Eagle Scout Award
And this was the first time these boys had ever seen it
And they didn't.
Boy Scouts didn't give a lot of information,
They just sort of said you had to have a certain number of merit badges.
and they had a drawing of the Eagle Medal
And it was very different from what we think of as the Eagle Medal.
It was a straight ribbon with one color, monochromatic.
They didn't know what color it was.
It was a black and white book
And an eagle in flight flying sideways
And that's all they knew.
And there weren't really enough merit badges
to get to the Eagle yet
Available, but Boy Scouts promised they'd have more.
So that's kind of where things stood.
So all across America boys were earning these ranks.
Well, Arthur Elder was one of these singular characters
And he sort of is the embodiment of what we think of
as that overachieving Eagle Scout.
Eagle Scouts are inevitably-
I've mentored about 50 of them.
I know you have mentored probably at least that many.
These kids are focused and they go for it.
And if scouting is said you have to have 150 merit badges,
we still have Eagle Scouts
because these are the kinds of young men
who are goal-oriented and they'll do it. whatever it takes,
However many hours and how much blood, sweat and tears,
they'll get there.
Well, Arthur saw the number, the 21 merit badges,
which was even true then-
and went out and got as many merit badges he could possibly get.
And then, when scouting finally announced
the next set of merit badges,
he went out and got those.
And he got them at a pace that is unprecedented
and will never again be equal
At one point, as near as I can figure,
when he had about 17 or 18 merit badges.
he had more merit badges, I believe,
than all the other Scouts in the United States.
So it's sort of like Babe Ruth.
You know, Babe Ruth in the early 1920s
one year had more home runs
than the entire rest of the American League.
Well, that's kind of what Arthur Elder was like 15 years before that.
He just simply fell in love with getting merit badges
and he got them all.
Well, now he had a problem
because no one knew what he was supposed to do next,
including the voiceouts from America.
So it said, you know, they said:
well, you have to have approval for all of this
from your local leaders.
So he ran around and got
letters of recommendation from all the local civic figures
in his town in Long Island
and he sent those in.
Well, at this point Scouting was rocked on its heels
because it had not expected this to happen.
Scouting has a tendency to announce these major new initiatives
and then is surprised when these over-achieving voiceouts
earn these things long before the institution's prepared for them.
He finishes the Eagle, he notifies Scout headquarters in Manhattan
and all hell breaks with him
and he goes. oh no, we weren't even expecting an Eagle for five more years
and this kid comes along and he's got it.
What are we going to do now?
They invite him down to New York City
and they give him a border review.
And obviously this is the institution saying
we better make sure this kid is actually for real
because we're going to have to announce him
as the first Eagle Scout in history
and we hope he's presentable.
So they bring him down
and they put him into a border review
with the founders of Scouting- all of them.
We wear medals named after him,
like the Voice Award, and all the rest of these guys,
these legends, and somehow he went into this border review
and came out alive.
It must have been very much like a Star Chamber.
I don't think any Eagle Scout- I'm sure
no other Eagle Scout in history-
had to face a border review like this one.
Well, is this? am I right?
Do I remember reading that Ernest Thompson Seaton
is on this board and Dan Beard?
Yeah, I remember Ernest Thompson Seaton and Dan Beard
hated each other
because they had invented the two founding organizations
that became Boy Scouts that, in fact,
the Brits had copied.
The original book on the outdoors
was the one that Baden Powell lifted from
to create the original Boy Scout handbook.
So these middle-aged men sitting there
facing Arthur Eldred had all sorts of
access to grind and feuds against each other
and everything else.
To my mind, as impressive as Arthur Eldred's achievement-
earning all those merit patches- was
surviving that group may have been his.
that may have qualified him more than anything else.
He must have been an amazing negotiator.
So he walks out, the very first Eagle Scout.
Well, now Scouting's got another problem.
Nobody ever made the medal.
They've got a drawing.
That's literally all they have.
All they have is the drawing and the Boy Scout handbook.
And so
And so Boyz has to send a note to Arthur Eldred saying
the medal isn't ready yet.
Can you wait until fall?
So what's Eldred going to do?
Fine, Yes, I'll wait until fall.
Well, while he's waiting,
he goes off to Boy Scout camp with his troop
And in the middle of his camp,
swimming in a lake,
one of the boys starts to drown.
Eldred goes in after him,
along with another scout,
to save the kid.
Well, as often happens,
as they teach you in life-saving, as you remember,
people that go in to save people
sometimes get into the stress themselves.
So Arthur goes in, he saves the kid that's drowning.
but now he's got the other kid who's starting to drown
and so he saves him too.
So we have this amazing character
who earns more merit badges
than anybody in all of Boy Scouts combined.
He then survives this star chamber
with the founders of scouting for his border review.
Then, while he's waiting to get his award,
he earns the honor medal for life-saving twice.
And this is all in the course of, you know, a summer.
So Arthur had a pretty good year.
Come fall they finally give him the Eagle Medal
and it's completely different
than the one in the book. thank goodness,
because we end up with.
you can see the medal even now
it's in the museum, in the Boy Scout Museum in Texas.
They give him the medal that looks
almost exactly like the one we all wear now.
So that's Arthur Eldred, a remarkable man,
And goes on and stays involved
all the way up through the 30s
and sits on boards of reviews.
Yeah, he becomes a very
you think. well, he's going to be like Neil Armstrong.
you know he's going to do a few things,
but in a sense, once again
he embodies what being an Eagle Scout is.
He becomes this responsible, trusted citizen
who sits on various civic committees.
His job is on these various industrial boards,
you know, for quality and that sort of thing,
just live a solid, honest life of a good citizen
and gets back involved in scouting
and his son becomes an Eagle Scout
And there's a picture of Arthur in his 50s,
you know, with gray hair
and giving the award to his son
And the line of Eldred's ever since
has earned Eagle Scouts.
I think we're fourth or fifth-generation Eldred's now
with Eagle Metal.
But after he earns the medal in 1912,
he just sort of fades from scouting history
until 50, 60 years later
they begin to. you know,
like a lot of institutions,
they don't start thinking about their history
until they have some major milestone
And scouting and it's 50th anniversary,
really begin to think about its past
and start to try to document it
and discovered it had lost a lot of its records
And it took a while to find it was Arthur
and then it took even longer
to actually find a photo of him.
Every honor he gets he deserves.
He's an amazing person.
Well, he kind of invented the Eagle,
you know. in some ways,
I mean, and what he did
he was just as much an inventor of it
as anybody else, it seems.
Oh, absolutely
Yeah.
Oftentimes these individuals.
they force institutions to respond to them
and in doing so
they drive the definition of what something is.
I'm going to break in
from just when I was giving an update
on the stuff adult leaders say T-shirt.
If you haven't heard about this,
go over to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the link that says a T-shirt just for us.
It's a Kickstarter project
and we're doing really great.
We have 13 days left to go.
We're 40% funded,
We have 35 backers
and I wanted to say thank you
to all those who've backed the project
on Kickstarter
and all of you who have sent in ideas
about exactly what should go on the T-shirt.
It's been a lot of fun
and let's keep it going.
The project closes in a little less than two weeks
and I can't offer any more T-shirts after that.
The only way to get one
is to make sure you get over and make a pledge,
and there's a link to get you there
at scoutmastercgcom.
So thanks very much once again, folks,
for participating,
and let's get back to the interface.
Arthur's story of going on
kind of leads into the idea that
by the 1920s
these boys who were earning Eagle Scout,
they would become 18,
they would age out of the organization.
But there was some response to that
and it resulted in an organization
that used to be very well known,
but I don't know that anybody
really knows about it anymore-
the Knights of Dunamis.
How did that all come about?
And you're talking to one
of the last surviving Knights-
Really
There aren't many of us left.
I got my Eagle very young
and I became a Knight of Dunamis,
I think when I was 16 or 17,.
stayed until I was 21,,
and that was the early 1970s,
And it was basically an organization
to take Eagle Scouts
and to organize them and use them
to perform service to Scouting
and to the community,
Not really from the time you became an Eagle,
but usually from the time you left your troop
and you joined a chapter
and ultimately there was about 50 chapters
or 100 chapters around the United States,
several thousand members.
I was a chapter president in San Jose
in the late 60s, early 70s
and we did everything from
honor guard in the Cinco de Mayo
parade to putting on children's
Christmas shows in hospitals,
to holding probably 100
Eagle Court of Honors.
we would preside over them
with our robes on and all that.
So it was really a remarkable organization
that did a tremendous amount of things.
Amazing organization.
It's what really made me think of myself
as an Eagle Scout.
But by the 1970s and 80s
it was fading.
Scouting gave it one last chance
and by then it was too late.
And so I found myself
at the 1973 National Jamboree
In Pennsylvania standing in front of about
10,000 Eagle Scouts
announcing the death. I was a part of the program.
I announced the death of the Knights of Dunamis
and the founding of the National Eagle Scout Association.
And you're still involved in that.
Yeah, I'm the president of the local NISA chapter,
Much more structured than the Knights of Dunamis was.
I missed the old Knights of Dunamis
and my hope is that NISA,
as it develops, will become more
like that, more service-oriented,
become an institution itself.
And I think the first really good step
was the creation of the Adams Award,
which is that award for the best
Eagle project in the United States.
That's a pretty recent thing, yeah,
Yeah, it's just three years old
And, remarkably enough,
my oldest son
earned the first
Adams Award.
He won the award for the Western Region.
He actually got a bunch of Silicon Valley
CEOs and VCs to buy
a 50-foot shipping container.
He filled it full of about three schools worth of supplies
and sent it off to
Children's Town, AIDS Orphanage
and School in Zambia
where we had visited,
And the container itself
was turned into a library.
This is a glimpse of what
21st Century Eagle projects look like.
There's a good section of the book
about these awards and things
which are really new and not a whole lot of people
really know about.
But what was the genesis of the Eagle project?
You didn't always do a project
to become an Eagle Scout.
No, and in fact you know
you always ran into these old Eagle Scouts.
I was much tougher back in the old days.
Nobody had as hard as we did getting our Eagle.
There's a little bit of truth to that.
Earning an Eagle in the 1920s
or 30s or 40s
was actually not that difficult,
except for one merit batch-
Bird study. Nobody got that merit batch.
There are thousands
of elderly men
who will tell you that they never got the Eagle
because they couldn't pass bird study.
But in terms of the overall requirements,
modern scouting is much more difficult
and that has to do with the Eagle project.
There was a feeling that because scouting
was growing so fast during the baby boomer era
that a lot of kids were getting their Eagles
but not really getting deep into scouting,
so there was a requirement for
participation
in community service,
and they still exist.
Then, in the early 60s, it was decided that
no, that wasn't enough.
What we wanted the Eagles to do
was to take all the skills that they had learned
and to apply them
in some organized way
that required them to have a plan,
a project
and exhibit the skills of being a leader,
especially dealing with adults.
And that was the beginning
of the Eagle service project.
We got their Eagle in the late 60s
and they said-
I don't really remember,
I think we painted some benches at the park
and that was a very successful Eagle project
back in the late 60s.
But we have 300,000
teenage boys each year
performing
or creating
real, honest-to-goodness social enterprises,
doing social entrepreneurship
and changing the face of this country.
And because these tend to be
discreet, comparatively small
events
that get coverage in the local paper
but no one puts it all together
and says good lord,
these Eagle scouts
are the single most
important force of-
I don't know what you call it-
social improvement in the United States
at any given time.
You quoted in the book
the figure 10.5 million hours.
Is that right?
Yeah, 10.5 million hours a year
on Eagle projects.
And if you add it up over the history
of Eagle scouting,
we're looking at about 100 to 150 million hours
of
civic contribution
by Eagle projects,
which makes it the largest service project
by youth in history.
There's simply nothing like it.
Just amazing what these kids are doing nowadays.
Yeah, from the small to the big,
they all add up into this incredible force.
Yes, they absolutely do.
Yeah, it's just amazing.
Now we recently
marked the passing of Neil Armstrong,
who's got to be probably
arguably the most famous
Eagle scouts.
Yeah, it's Neil Armstrong,
And I'm in a weird position
of I think I'm the last
person to have worked with Neil Armstrong,
Really.
Yeah, because
when we had the book in draft,
we had access to
Dr Armstrong
And I asked him. I said:
I've written this chapter about you,
but I'm not sure it's accurate.
Would you check it out?
He was famously prickly about not dealing
with the media,
not doing any publicity.
At one point I made the mistake
of asking if he'd give me a jacket quote
and I got it immediate.
No, I don't do that,
But
a few weeks. you know we're coming up on
deadline. it's going to be close.
24 hours later he sent me back
three pages of email
correcting every little detail.
So I'm sitting in my house
emailing back and forth with Neil Armstrong-
which was pretty mind-boggling-
And then
I realized a week later,
when it was announced that he'd gone in for heart surgery,
that he had literally finished editing
his chapter for me like 48 hours
before he went to the hospital.
I assumed he was coming out.
Oh my gosh,
Or I can't believe that he would have devoted the time to this
If he thought it was that serious.
So
I put a little note on the bottom of that
chapter.
It's quite an amazing thing
And once again,
sort of an eagle scout
being helpful.
The book has just dozens of different stories
about
eagles who went on to distinguish themselves
in various ways,
And some of them used to be pretty much
household names
And you bring them back to memory,
and one that I wanted to ask you to talk about a little bit
is Paul Cyple.
He's a very interesting guy
And you could argue until Neil Armstrong
comes on the scene.
The shiny example of what an eagle scout is
was Paul Cyple for
40 years,
The middle era of scouting.
He's the man,
He's the guy.
You read this and you look at your own
When you put on your eagle medal, you think,
wow, am I worthy to wear the medal
to that, Neil Armstrong
and Arthur Eldridge and Paul Cyple.
Cyple is
sort of the ultimate eagle scout.
When you think of an eagle scout he's a great big guy:
big, toothy grin,
affable and friendly with everyone.
A natural leader
earned his eagle, I think when he was
18 or 18 and a half.
You were on your way to eagle.
You were allowed to go on and finish it
after your 18th birthday.
It was already accepted into college.
I think he had 30 merit badges.
He had done a lot of 50 milers.
He was the real deal.
Commodore Perry is going to
go to the South Pole.
He publicly announced that he was going to take
one eagle scout
with him
to Antarctica.
He was going to have a national competition.
Cyple hears about it and applies.
The list is swiddled down to
10 or 12 boys,
All of them
super overachievers from around the country.
The story is covered in every paper in America.
It's a very big deal.
Cyple shines above all of these
other overachievers and Perry agrees to take him.
The plan is
he's going to go along and he's going to
go on the ship, sailing down there
and working the galley.
By the time they get to Antarctica
he's already moved out of the galley,
He's up on deck and he's starting
to take care of the animals.
He turns out to be
incredibly strong
and more capable than
the professionals that Perry's brought with him.
As a result, he ends up
being Perry's number two guy
within about two months.
He's just this amazing guy
and everybody loves him
because he's such a nice guy
Over. he's Perry's protege
and when he comes back he goes to college
and he's celebrated
and fetid and all that.
Perry goes down again and is going to fly
over to South Pole.
He invites Cyple to be his guy,
to go with him down there to do it,
And so Cyple slowly becomes.
especially as Perry gets older,
Cyple becomes the world's
leading art explorer
And he not only begins
to explore Antarctica
but also the Arctic.
And when World War II
breaks out, he's doing
scientific research and they ask him
to investigate
different kinds of weather
systems and environments
for soldiers to fight in,
What kind of uniforms they need, and all that.
And while he's at it, he invents
the notion of windshield factor.
So whenever you hear
windshield factor, he's in front of
an NFL football game or something
and he just becomes
one of the greatest applied
scientists America has ever produced.
For long as I've been involved in this guy-
no doubt as long as you've been involved-
there's always been a lot of
discussions that
tend to turn into arguments
about what constitutes an eagle scout.
Yeah,
People can get pretty exercised about it.
You've
had an interesting
perspective of that question.
Is there an answer?
There's simple answers and there's complicated answers.
The simple answer is:
being an eagle scout is a state of mind.
One of the amazing things about the eagle award is
it's the only award of childhood that stays with you
your entire life.
You go in the military. you can wear your eagle medal,
a special version of it.
When you're 90 years old and you die,
your paper in your obituary is likely
to mention the fact that you were an eagle scout.
It's not going to mention you were varsity football
or anything else you did as a kid.
It's going to attach to you your entire life
and to be cognizant of that fact
and to live up to it
is to be a true eagle scout.
That's the simple answer.
There's a more complicated answer
and
you've dealt with it a lot in your blog.
A lot of the people writing in commenting-
especially people asking for advice-
a lot of people write in and say
we've decided not to let this boy
become an eagle because we don't think he's worthy.
That's that whole messy business
of do you fit
the stereotype of an eagle scout,
And that one
always bugs me
and I think it bugs most eagles.
I've found that people
who are adults, who are eagle scouts,
are usually a lot more flexible
about scouts becoming eagles.
I think you don't
really become an eagle scout
when they put that medal on you.
I think it's something that
you grow into over time.
as I think I've written to you
in the past,
Nobody gets to eagle easy.
You become an eagle. if you
earn the eagle
and you're serious about it, you become an eagle.
You may finally become an eagle
when you're 30.
You may do it when you're 15..
But if you live the eagle life,
you become an eagle.
That's a really good way of looking at it
and maybe it'll help inform people
who get a little exercised about this
in a while.
I'm weary of that.
We've put enormous stress
upon these kids,
That sort of unwritten rule
that your eagle project
now has to change mankind forever.
That's an awful lot
to put on a teenage boy.
Boys are ready to do their eagle project
when they're ready to do their eagle project,
and not a day before,
Not a minute before.
They're terrified.
They don't want to deal with adults,
They don't want to organize anything,
And then one morning they get up and decide
I'm going to do it,
And then they're focused and they pull it off.
Was there anything in writing the book
that you discovered that
changed the way that you look at this at all,
or that you just were unaware of
and you thought was
something pretty incredible?
I think the thing that struck me the most
was that eagle scouting
stands apart from Boy Scouting.
It's a classic example
of being of scouting,
but not necessarily part of scouting.
Once you start on the trail
of the eagle beginning
when you become a life,
you enter into a different reality
and you move down that path,
and that path has been taken for 100 years
by
what?
five to six million boys ahead of you,
And it's a fraternity
And
it's filled with like-minded people,
all of whom have
decided that they're going to go for something
that's bigger than anything they've ever done in their lives
and that's going to challenge them
in ways they can't imagine.
And
I was struck by that continuity,
that eagle scouting really is a thing
unto itself
When you have this group of people
that are these kind of overachievers
and who did something this big
at such a young age.
they're going to cut their own path
for the rest of their lives,
So you can't control them:
Former members who are still officially members,
who are presidents of universities
and Nobel Prize winners
and Medal of Honor awardees
and members of Congress.
they're a heck of a lot more powerful
than scouting itself
And I love that about it.
And when you go to an eagle court of honor
and they form the eagle court,
inviting everybody from the audience to come up,
they're going to rise of all ages,
from their 20s to their 80s
and you know, it's colored their entire life.
Everywhere you go,
you're going to run into an eagle scout
and he's going to be the guy
who's in the position of greatest responsibility.
And that's an amazing thing,
It's a powerful thing,
and writing the book,
I felt enormous pride
in this fraternity that I was part of
and felt compelled even more
to be an eagle scout.
like an eagle scout.
My prediction is it's going to become
the default thing
that you get for a new eagle scout.
Well, thank you very much.
Let me ask you this question, since I get asked it regularly.
Right now the book's available
in a Kindle edition
and I know it's doing very well.
When are we going to get the regular good old fashion
hardcover edition of it?
Well, I can't commit to a precise state,
but I know that the publisher
is creating an index for it right now
and we're working with
Nisa, with Bill Steele,
in hopes that we can get
the photos that we want to put in the book.
So I can't make a precise commitment
or even a precise date,
but I think pretty soon.
I would love to see the book available for Christmas,
But it is going to happen
one way or the other.
If I can help it, it will.
If I can help it, it would too.
I've got a shelf of books
and I don't know how to file on the shelf
an electronic version of a book.
Well, I still think.
when people have asked me
whether or not they can get it in a hard copy,
I tell them that
it's still a great gift
for a new Eagle Scout,
because that's usually what they're asking.
They want to get it for somebody who's just becoming an Eagle.
Yeah, they all have Kindle's and iPads. anyway,
They'll figure out how to read it,
even if we can't.
Well, I'm watching the time here.
I've kept you a bit longer
than I said at first.
It's so much fun to read your blog.
I turned to it before
anything else in scouting.
Oh well, thank you,
And I think your comment section is brilliant.
You get a lot of interesting people
that are very committed to scouting.
Yeah, that's probably the best part of doing it,
And I constantly take
your outdoor lists,
like the survival kit you did the other day,
and I email it out
through our troop
Yahoo Group email.
I'm glad to hear people find stuff useful.
Oh, there you go.
That's good.
Once again, the book's 4%-
The Story of Uncommon Youth in a Century of American Life,
And we've been talking
with Mike Malone, the author.
Thanks very much for joining us, Mike.
Thank you, Clark, and best to all of your loyal readers.
Thank you for listening to this
278th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch:
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom
and there you can read our blog
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can join the other mobile scouters
who have the ScoutmasterCG app
on their mobile devices
and you can get the app in the Google Play
or iCloud.
You can get the app
in the Google Play or iTunes app store.
You can experience all the wonders
that are ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join the 9,500 folks
who like ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook,
Tweet along with the course of
1,200 tweeters on Twitter
and pin the poultry tuna's pictures
that we profit publicly with
1,900 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch as it's ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive
and very quiet ScoutmasterCG circle
on Google Plus.
Now, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
don't worry about it, that's okay.
Bunky, Zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me,
ClarkGreen, at Clark
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
and
let me remind you, please,
that the Scoutmaster Blog
and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are not official publications of anybody
except for myself. Nope,
they're not official publications of any
scouting organization like the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by anybody.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to
scouters and have a little bit of fun
along the way. and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert
Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.